Critics and fans alike love the
final installment of the "Guardians
of the Galaxy" trilogy, but one iconic
accessory was conspicuously absent from
the blockbuster. And now, director James
Gunn has weighed in on making that call.
Star-Lord and his space buddies surpassed
expectations for "Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 3," earning huge box office numbers as the
Marvel Cinematic Universe underdogs. This final
“Guardians” entry gives a poignant farewell to
its titular misfits, and many viewers praised
James Gunn for his perfect swan song. However,
some fans wondered about its finer details.
One common question on Twitter
after the film’s release was
“What happened to Star-Lord’s helmet?”
which he never wears in the threequel.
"Well, that's a good question."
We know he gets a new one between
“Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2” and “Avengers:
Infinity War,” but its status in his
latest adventure puzzled many fans.
Fortunately, we have an answer for why Quill’s
essential headwear — and his clip-on rocket
boots — were missing. Gunn recently explained
that because of the urgency of his mission
to rescue his best friend Rocket Raccoon,
he left his iconic Guardians gear behind.
On Twitter, where he often shares
insights directly with fans,
Gunn set the record straight about Quill
not wearing a helmet in "Vol. 3." in a
tongue-in-cheek reply. In response
to one user's question, he joked,
"It's in his desk drawer [on] Knowhere. He
had to get out of there fast as you know!"
While this lack of helmet can be easily
forgiven, his enhanced footwear accessories
very well could have made for handy
tools on his quest. As it turns out,
Gunn cleared up this particular matter as
well, in a less jokey manner, revealing that
the Guardians' technology has advanced by leaps
and bounds, all thanks to Rocket. Gunn posted,
"The rockets that clip onto his
boots are far inferior to the
jet packs Rocket has made them so
they're not around at all anymore."
Time and a supersmart raccoon, then,
are the simple answers to this apparent
change to Star-Lord's character.
Even so, there may still be a chance that we'll
see Quill back in his old gear down the line,
given that the ending of "Vol. 3"
confirms Chris Pratt's MCU future.
Otherwise, a lonely helmet somewhere on
Knowhere may no longer have an owner.
While Gunn may have jokingly explained
away Star-Lord's in-universe mentality
behind traveling without his helmet, some
fans in a Reddit thread about this subject
have proposed additional theories
about the decision. Gunn, of course,
could have easily justified keeping
the iconic headwear in "Vol. 3," but
chose instead to alter the character in
a way plenty of fans found noticeable.
In the thread's top comment, for example,
one user argued that Star-Lord's lack of
gear emphasizes his singular focus on
saving Rocket. Meanwhile, another fan
proposed that the film may simply be trying
to maximize Chris Pratt's on-screen face time,
in the same manner Steve Rogers inexplicably
fights without a helmet during big moments in
the "Avengers" films prior to Chris Evans' Marvel
Cinematic Universe exit. Another user wrote,
"I like this interpretation some people had
where Peter wanted to distance himself from
Star Lord. Ties in nicely with how
he went back to Earth at the end,
to his roots as a human
being and with his grandpa."
Since he leaves the Guardians team at the
end of the film, it's entirely possible,
then, that Peter Quill will remain unmasked
in his future appearances — a new direction
for his character as he remains a
big part of the post-"Guardians" MCU.